based on george rr martin's book fire
and blood this new show takes place 300
years before game of thrones
it tells the story of house targaryen in
the earlier days of westeros
i don't want to give away too much but
what i will tell you is that house of
the dragon is co-created and executive
produced by george
and ryan condell and also executive
produced and directed by miguel
sapochnick
miguel of course is one of the most
masterful game of thrones directors
he won an emmy for the unforgettable
episode battle of the bastards
we couldn't be happier to have found the
next great chapter in georgia saga and
we wanted this news to bring our
presentation our content presentation to
a close
thank you all very much for your time
today
[Music]
you